el nuevo coronavirus parece ser bastante
resistente cuando se trata de sobrevivir
en distintos lugares así lo demostró la
agencia científica australiana si es hoy
según la cual el virus responsable del
cobi 19 permanece hasta 28 días en
superficies lisas como pantallas
telefónicas de vidrio acero y billetes
de polímero a una temperatura de 20
grados
cuando aumentamos la temperatura la
supervivencia del virus se acortó
ciertamente hasta los 40 grados al virus
sobrevivido generalmente menos de 24
horas así que de cara al verano este va
a ser un factor importante
en comparación con estudios anteriores
que mostraban que el coronavirus podía
sobrevivir hasta cuatro días en
superficies no porosas esto es
significativamente más largo pero estos
resultados son válidos en condiciones de
laboratorio por ejemplo el experimento
se llevó a cabo en la oscuridad cuando
ya se ha demostrado que la luz
ultravioleta mata el virus
[Música]
en el mundo real esas superficies
probablemente estarán en contacto con
luz solar
[Música]
también estarán en diferentes humedades
diferentes temperaturas por lo tanto en
el mundo real los resultados
probablemente serán más cortos de lo que
pudimos demostrar
aunque el virus pueda sobrevivir por más
de lo pensado no se sabe a ciencia
cierta hasta qué punto puede generar
nuevas infecciones las principales vías
de contagio siguen siendo las gotículas
expulsadas por las personas al toser o
estornudar los expertos se esperan que
el estudio ayude a desarrollar nuevas
estrategias de mitigación